bonjour albert moleka bonjour madame
merci beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin
dans la matinale verte et france en
direct de kinshasa on voit réagira à ce
qui s'est passé ce week-end deux
attaques attribués à l'organisation et à
islamique dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo est ce qu'on en
sait un peu plus sur l'origine
l'assaillant serait d'origine ougandaise
et écoutez le le communiqué des essarts
baisser si très clairement que c'est
ces attentats ont été organisées par la
structure opérationnelle de l'adeif
alliés donc de l'état de l'état issami
et certains individus qui étaient
impliqués dans dans cette attente en dg
été identifié et l'enquêté suit son
cours
vous parlez de l'adf cette rébellion qui
est présente dans l'est de la république
démocratique depuis 25 ans ils ont fait
alliance avec l'organisation état
islamique est ce que vous pouvez nous
nous expliquer qu'ils sont ces rebelles
et à quels sont leurs liens avec
l'organisation terroriste
ecoutez-la des fêtes 1 c'est une
structure assez complexe d'ailleurs vous
verrez qu'il y à il ya deux camps qui
s'affrontent dans la confirmation de la
relation de la dette avec l'état
islamique et même de l'existence
véritable de de la dette nous savons
tous à l'origine que l'index est une est
une organisation rebelle était opposé au
régime de kampala au régime de résidence
et béni en ouganda en ouganda et l'état
pour eux des frontières à l'est du pays
se faisait une cervelle de nouvelles
toujours un refuge du côté congolais
nous ils pouvaient mener leur attaque
surprise ans en ouganda
la plupart des personnes
entendu parler de la nef lorsque nous
allons du pendant leur année c'est vague
de massacres de populations en rdc dans
le territoire de dans le territoire de
béni
c'est là où la leffe est devenu très
très connu au niveau au niveau
international mais il y a une autre
école de pensée si je puis dire qui
prétend que en vérité les véritables
adeptes ne sont pas chez nous ce que
nous voulons mais c'est le combattre
avec eux la leffe aurait une telle
personne revendu sa marque déposée et
donc son nom à certains états ou un
certain gouvernement et qu'ils utilisent
pour mener leurs grands musées jégo
nique sur l'est de la de la rdc
quel intérêt pour eux de s'allier à
l'organisation état islamique wes à
l'organisation états islamiques d'avoir
un intérêt à s'allier à ces groupes
rebelles où il est la définition de cet
intérêt reste encore aures remporte ou
quoi que on peut dire que la rb c'est un
territoire immense où l'autorité de
l'état a toujours eu de nous rencontrer
les difficultés à se manifester et du
rand et les 25 derrière d'année pour la
rdc peut constituer un endroit idéal
justement pour promouvoir cette
politique de l'état islamiste et une
sente noter les ressources toutes les
ressources du 600 ui au bord gorge elle
est là la république démocratique du
congo
tu peux contribuer au financement de ce
terrorisme la rdc pourrait devenir un
nouveau refuge en tout cas pour ces
terroristes de l'organisation état
islamique en afrique on le voit avec la
propagation du terrorisme dans le sahel
par exemple oui bien sûr bien cher mais
non seulement un refuge pour les les
dette mais terroristes en termes
militaires de la rdc est déjà un refuge
pour les terroristes financier et
économique
le mode opératoire le fait de porter des
engins explosifs ces nouveaux également
en termes de d'opérations menées contre
des églises on a en parlé aussi
nouvelles cibles de ces terroristes
je peux dire que c'est nouveau dans le
sens que c'est déjà un pas vers les
attaques suicides vers les attentats
suicides etc
on a comparé assister à ce genre à ce
genre d'opération cela ajoute toujours à
la terreur est recherché par ces groupes
que les églises soit ciblée est ce que
c'est aussi un nouveau et est ce que ça
apporte évidemment la marque des
terroristes et la communauté chrétienne
qui est ciblé que les églises soient
soient ciblées dans les violences
politiques entre guillemets ce n'est pas
nouveau les églises l'église catholique
a souvent fait les frais le de la
violence de la violence politique mais
je crois que cela ne fait qu'ajouter
encore ou supplémentaires à à la qualité
qu'on introduit à la baisse
dallier état islamiste selon vous
comment lutter contre eux alors c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas que la dèche il ya
plusieurs groupes rebelles en rdc mais
que fait le gouvernement pour essayer
d'y mettre un terme
bon le gouvernement a décidé depuis
début mai depuis le 6 mai d'instaurer
l'état de siège dans deux provinces de
l'est et le nord kivu se trouve la ville
de beni là où les attentats ont été
perpétrés ainsi que l'ituri et au nord
du nord-kivu en vue de rétablir
l'autorité de l'état et de préserver
l'existence et le fonctionnement des
institutions qui depuis
plus ou moins 25 ans avait quasiment
disparu avait disparu de ses compris en
termes de solutions bon ça commence à
fonctionner selon les communiqués les
rapports des forces armées il faut dire
que les moyens ont été mis ou été mis à
disposition des gouverneurs militaires
seulement récemment et qui fait que lynx
la logistique se met peu à peu en place
et nous espérons tous que cet état de
siège
amen effectivement la paix pour ces
populations qui ont tant souffert
aujourd'hui il ya il y à un couvre feu
imposé
les écoles sont fermées les églises
également la population comment
réagit-elle à 7
ces nouvelles attaques en à population
par rapport à ces attaques est habitué à
cette violence tant qu'on peut ce temps
qu'on puisse s'habituer à ce genre de
violence mais il y a il a toujours
existé une méfiance entre la population
et les forces armées
je crois que les premiers des grands
défis de cet état de siège c'est de
recréer la confiance entre la population
et les l armée nationale est là pour la
protéger et pour restaurer la paix
pourquoi cette méfiance l'origine de
cette méfiance prévu au fait que trop
souvent il ya eu collusion entre des
éléments des forces armées et même des
officiers des forces armées et les
groupes rebelles pas seulement la leffe
d'une multitude vous probert avec le
groupe d'étude sur le congo avait avait
identifié de 120 armes et danse dans la
région du nord kivu et du et de l'ituri
et cette collusion entre les forces
armées et les groupes armés
à créer c'est l'émergence eu des coupes
patriote on appelle my mind qui eux sont
des groupes qui défendent
essentiellement leurs communautés ce ne
sont pas des groupes à volonté
hégémonique comme comme d'autres groupes
qui sont aussi soutenues très souvent
par les états voisins
merci beaucoup albert moleka pour toutes
ces explications en direct ce matin de
kinshasa